just as the night is dark and full of
terrors the Internet is vast and full of
spoilers Game of Thrones has but two
episodes remaining in its epic eight
season run on television and thanks to a
series of purported leaks fans may
already have the answer as to how the
show will end naturally beware of some
potentially massive spoilers for the
final episodes of the show leaks for
Game of Thrones season 8 began surfacing
online several months before the series
return to HBO in April and have
continued to crop up on various forums
as the season has aired that leaked
information has been compiled by the
Game of Thrones subreddit our free folk
with a recent update including potential
details about the last half of the final
season though many were initially
hesitant to take the leaks at face value
information provided about episode 4 of
the season wound up being startling ly
accurate with that in mind people have
become much more inclined to believe the
leaks about the last two episodes are
true according to the post on reddit the
remaining episodes of Game of Thrones
season 8 will allegedly feature the
following developments not necessarily
in this order now's the time to look
away Daenerys and her army will capture
Jaime Lannister who was last seen
heading back to King's Landing
Dany also gives orders to execute Varys
presumably for committing treason with
his increasing inclinations towards
supporting Jon Snow and protecting the
citizens of the realm
I will act in their interest no matter
the personal cost he is reportedly
burned alive all the while tyrion begs
Daenerys to show mercy and attempts to
resign his hand which she refuses Jon
Snow also attempts to reason with her
and fails instead of keeping a cool head
in the face of resistance something
snaps in Dany and she decides to storm
King's Landing
against her advisors wishes her forces
easily take the city in a one-sided
fight and she also finally gets her
chance to light up your on Greyjoy and
the iron fleet from there the leaked
information alleges that Daenerys and
her unsullied army will dole out extreme
violence in King's Landing
they're alienating Tyrion and John she
begins executing many people fed up with
Daenerys increasingly unhinged actions
Tyrion frees Jaime and even attempts to
get Cersei to safety as well the leaks
also claim that the chaos in King's
Landing will serve as the backdrop to
the long awaited Clegane bowl also known
as the battle between brothers the Hound
and the mountain both characters
apparently died in the conflict the
mother of dragons apparently now in full
Mad Queen mode arrests Sirian for
freeing Jaime and sentences him to be
executed
Tyrion then allegedly does a complete
180 on his allegiance to Daenerys and
begins attempting to convince Jon to
turn on her in his view Jon and the
stark family will never be safe from an
unhinged generis because Jon's claim to
the throne serves as a threat to her
legitimacy Jon tries to talk to her but
is ignored with Daenerys believing her
actions are justified with that avenue
exhausted Tyrion teams up with Sansa to
devise a plan to overthrow Dany and turn
John against her despite agreeing to the
plot at first Sansa ultimately betrays
Tyrion I used to think you're the
cleverest man why Tyrians trial is set
to take place in the dragon pit and is
said to have Samwell Tarly Brienne of
Tarth grey worm and Robin Arryn of all
people in attendance among others Tyrion
gives an enraged and resentful monologue
criticizing the onlookers for turning
against him despite his many sacrifices
for the people of King's Landing but he
can't talk his way out of this one he
slumps to his knees defeated though the
details aren't clear yet he reportedly
dies that's not all
additionally Jaime will fight Euron
killing the crazed Greyjoy man but
sustaining fatal injuries himself Jaime
is said to make his way back to Cersei
and the two die together though who
kills who and why is still unknown
finally the leaks make a bold claim
about how Jon and Danny's story ends
after failing to get through to Daenerys
and make her see that her sack of King's
Landing was wrong
Jon ultimately kills her according to
the purported leaks Kit Harington shot
two possible endings for his character
so
John will either take the black and join
a new night's watch or die before the
end of the final episode this
information reportedly comes from
several different sources that mostly
corroborate each other though some leaks
have information that other sources
don't according to one leak the series
will end with a council deciding that
brand should rule the Seven Kingdoms
Sansa will rule the north and Samwell
Bronn and sir Davos will serve as brands
advisers interestingly this leak also
insists that Tyrion will be among
brand's advisers contradicting the other
leaks that say he dies it also seems to
contradict brands previous statements
about desiring any kind of power at all
and that's it that's the information
that's out there parts of it may well be
true and other parts may be deliberate
misinformation ceded by the production
to muddy the spoiler waters either way
it sounds like an ending that's
determined to frustrate ending the
series on what sounds like an incredibly
divisive note only time will tell but if
the bulk of these turn out to be
accurate let's just say that King's
Landing isn't the only thing that will
go up in flames the internet probably
will - check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]